for more than a year athea ibrahim has
been coming to protest in central
baghdad
to demand better services political
reform and an
end to what he says has been decades of
government corruption
and mismanagement but he's here today
because like many iraqis he is shocked
and angry about the government's
recent devaluation of the iraqi dna
against the dollar
by more than 20 percent we are stunned
by the government's action
i will effectively lose almost quarter
of my salary because i'm paid in dinners
the finest minister says it won't affect
us
how will it not the government said it
had to devalue
iraq's currency because of a collapse in
the oil prices
brought on by a slump in global energy
demands
due to the coronavirus pandemic
this devaluation is the biggest since
the fall of saddam hussein in 2003 and
experts are saying it means
the already abysmal economic situation
for millions of iraqis
could get even worse this is baghdad's
usually bustling wholesale market but
it's been very quiet since the
devaluation
of the dinar the collapse in iraq's
industrial and food producing sectors in
recent decades
means most food and domestic products
are imported
from neighboring countries especially
turkey and iran
i bought goods at the old dollar price
and now i have to sell at the devalued
price so i have to put my prices up or
i'll lose a lot of money
it hits everyday people the hardest and
there are no jobs because we don't have
economists or thinkers in charge
this means shopkeepers have had no
choice but to suddenly put
their prices up too
i still haven't received my government
pension and even when i do
it will be worth much less all the
prices have suddenly
increased of course it is affecting us
terribly
even before the currency devaluation the
world bank predicted a
sharp rise in poverty in iraq
almost 90 percent of iraqi government
revenue comes from oil
but plummeting prices have caused a cash
crisis
iraq's public sector has trebled in size
to more than four million employees
since 2003
delays in payment of government salaries
and the lack of private sector jobs
have fueled the protests hundreds of
people have been killed in the crackdown
no one has been called to account for
the deaths
it is a disaster is a disaster for the
middle class the lower class
but not the top class obviously but the
main reason
is corruption corruption is the one
because there are other
oil producing countries that are not
affected as iraq is
of course iraq sells oil in dollars so
they don't get affected
but the people are getting their
salaries in dinar and so
instead of ripping off the budget
they're ripping off the employees
themselves
and that means more financial hardship
for iraqis
and potentially more civil and political
unrest
charles stratford al-jazeera baghdad